Now if you look at the memory footprint of
a process. And the amount of time it takes to
load all of its working sect into the cache.
The, the bigger the memory footprint, the more time it's
going to take for the processor to get the working
set of a particular thread into the cache. So that
the cache is warm enough, and the process of
the thread can do its work. Without having to have
those hiccups where it has to go to the memory in order to fetch the contents in
the cache. So what this suggests is that it's
important to pay attention to cache affinity in scheduling.
And so the variance of cache affinity scheduling
that we talked about are all excellent candidates to
run on a multiprocessor. And in fact, the minimum
intervention, or minimum intervening scheduling policy, and the minimum
intervening scheduling with queuing, both of those are
very good policies to use when you have a
fairly light to medium load on a multiprocessor.
Because that is the time when it is likely
that a thread, when it is run on a processor, if it has an affinity for that
particular processor, the contents of the cache are going
to contain the memory contents for that particular thread.
But on the other hand, if you have a very
heavy load in the system, then it is likely that
by the time a thread is run on a processor,
on which it supposedly having an affinity, all of the
cache may have been polluted because the load is very
heavy. So, in between the time that a thread got
run on a particular processor, next time it runs on
the same processor, maybe it's cache contents have been highly polluted
by other threads. And therefore, if the load
is very heavy then maybe a fixed processor scheduling
may work out to be much better than
the variants of minimum intervening scheduling policies. So, the
moral of the story is that you really
have to pay attention to both how heavily loaded
your processor is, or system is and also what
is the kind of workload that you are catering
to, both those things play a part in
deciding what what we will be best scheduling policy
and it may not always be the case
that the same scheduling policy applies in all circumstances.
So, a real agile operating system may choose
to vary the scheduling policy based on the load
as well as the current set of threads that
need to run on the system. Another interesting wrinkle
to taking a scheduling policy is the idea of
procrastination. And that is, normally we think of the scheduler
when the processor is looking for work, it's going
to the, to the run queue and saying well I
need to, to do something.and let me pick the
next thread to run on myself. That's what a processor
is going to do. Perhaps procrastination may help. Why would
procrastination help? First of all, how do we implement procrastination?
Well, what the processor can do is, it is actually
ready to do, do some work. Now, what it does
is it, it's going to insert an idle loop. Why would
it insert an idle loop? It'll insert an idle loop
because it has, it's looking in the, the scheduling queue
and it sees that there is no thread in the
scheduling queue that has run on it before. And therefore,
if it schedules any one of those threads though all
of those threads are not going to find any of
their working set in the cache of the processor.
And therefore the processor says okay, now let me
just spin my wheels for a while, not schedule anything.
It is likely that a thread that has its
cache content in that processor becomes runable again. And
then you can schedule that, and that might be
a win, in terms of performance. So in other words,
procrastination may help boost performance. We saw that
already in the synchronization algorithms where we talked about
inserting delays in the scheduling algorithm in order to
reduce the amount of contention in the connection of
the network. It's the same sort of principle. Often
times you'll see in system design, procrastination actually helps
in boosting performance. It helps in the synchronizational rhythms,
it helps in scheduling and later on when we
talk about file systems you'll see that it
helps in the design of file systems also.